According to 1991 statistics, for
every,000 male
females
that means 7.3%
females less than male. from 28
to 7.
7.3
it increased by more than double
in the span of 90 years.
Why?
Why are the female killing increasing?
You know why? Because science and
technology is improving. You have
billboards in states like Rajasthan,
Tamil Nadu. Spend 500 rupees and say
500,000 rupees. Do amnio sentences or
ultra sonography when you're pregnant.
When the woman is identify that the baby
you're carrying is a girl about her for
500 rupees and save 500,000 rupees in
upbringing her and dowi. So as science
and technology is advancing
the female feticide is increasing.
That's the reason it increased to 3
million a year.
This is a pathetic state of our world
today.
Islam
not only condemns
the killing of female children, it even
condemns the thought of you feeling bad
at the birth of a female child.
Allah says in surah chapter number 16
verse number 15 and 59 when news is
brought to one of them of a birth of a
female child his face darkens
he's filled with inward grief
and he hides his face in shame from the
society and thinks should he let her
live in contempt or Should he let her
die or should he bury her in dust? Ah,
what an evil thought.
Leave aside
Quran condemning killing female infants.
Quran even condemned the thought of you
feeling sad at the birth of a female
child.
Our
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
it's a say hadith in which the prophet
said that if anyone upbringings two
daughters till they mature
with love and affection
they will be as close to me like these
two fingers in Akar.
There another hadith which says which
says if you upbringing two daughters
with love and affection till they mature
you shall enter paradise.
The prophet did not only talk
about women right he practically
demonstrated it. Once
there was a man who kissed his son and
asked him to sit on one of his lap but
did not do the same for his daughter who
was present there. The prophet objected
and said that he should even kiss his
daughter and place her on the other lap.
Let's discuss
the social status of a wife in Islam.
Unlike other societies
where women are considered as an
instrument of a devil. If you read
history, if you read the Greek history,
it talks about
a woman by the name of Pandora, which is
responsible for all the misfortune in
the world. If you read the Egyptian
civilization,
they consider the woman as an instrument
of the devil. In Islam, in the Quran,
the woman is called as a mahasana.
Mahasana means a fortress against the
devil. Because a pious wife, she will
keep a husband on the straight track
and prevent him from going on the wrong
track. She's referred to in the Quran as
moana, a fortress against the devil.